This is the theory of space
Air It's just a frozen food. Lighten this guy as stupid and boost the mobility of the boo corps.
Lighten the ramen.
No way a
We make cup ramen.
Hey, I've done it before, but after all, it freezes and dries according to the farming process. Freeze and dry it.
Freeze the ingredients and the water in the ramen becomes ice.
You can see
that when you put it in a vacuum, the air around you isn't there, so instead all the ice turns
into steam and disappears
.
What's the main book and how do you do it? It
was a work team for that.
[Music]
It's a tri-machine that uses the water wheel made by
Miyagare
.  I'm using what I've made with a whirlwind.
That's how humankind has accumulated over 200 years.
It was
science.
[Applause]
[Music]
Leeds-dried ramen  It's a
surf boot, it's certainly light and small, but it's normal, but it
's rusty, so
look at it
.  Don't hesitate to write a new sentence, Bick's way of life is a science messenger
. I said before that. There is no theory that I just want to eat first.
Tenezo
52 I
went
dare